[Music]
oh
man
[Music]
good morning good morning good morning
welcome back to the best business show
why is it the best business show it's
because we said it was the best and
that's how the world works this is the
show that my brothers and i wish that we
had when we were growing up learning
about investing business and finance i
am here with one of my brothers
john how do you know his name is john
real simple his name's on the back of
his chair and straight over here
continues
joe not here he will be back soon
shortly in joe's place we have a really
important guest today it is the atm
yes the atm is back
hey atm how was your night
okay great thanks for the great uh
commentary there no problem atm is still
here in the studio how the hell we got
the atm we're not really sure uh what
we're gonna do with it we're not sure
but i think that we're gonna might maybe
do a little live demo try to buy
something uh on the atm but yes we do
have a bitcoin atm in the studio now
pretty nuts
we got a lot to get through today let's
get right out of the gate here's the
three p oh go back to that shot that was
a great shot look at this right here
john me me john in a machine hanging out
what's up
uh in terms of today's show we've got a
ton of stuff uh to get through but
internet exclusive interview only here
on the best business show coinbase ceo
brian armstrong
we will have an interview with him it's
over an hour long
we talk coinbase we talk regulation we
talk the sec we talk about bitcoin nfts
dows company culture remote work etc
absolutely
nuts how much we got through in an hour
uh it is incredible and it will be
exclusively here uh and we even talk
about his twitter thread where he
tweeted about uh the sec etc so we go we
get into it all i think you guys will
really enjoy that conversation um and
before we get started don't forget that
the best business show with the best
partner the best partner is sofi
sofi.com pomp very simple you go there
you read the terms and conditions
obviously because it's the internet we
have to say in terms of conditions
thanks lawyers and then once you go to
sofi and you download the account you
can go you can buy 10 worth of bitcoin
and they will double you up you buy 10
bitcoin they give you 10 free of bitcoin
2x like that real simple i'm not a
genius neither are you
yesterday we found out that i'm actually
pretty good at public math uh
but you know hey whatever not gonna brag
right john
how'd you sleep last night are you good
to go uh yeah i slept well yeah cause
well i'm doing fantastic but your
coffee's on the table today you're doing
a little bit of promotion there like you
normally don't so i was just making sure
yeah
dot com slash pomp is the exclusive
sponsor of the best business show so far
has the best coffee they've got the best
app they got the best everything perfect
um all right let's jump right into it i
am going to do my absolute best to
explain uh uh some very nuanced tax uh
issues that are going on and then i'm
gonna walk you through why this is
absolute insanity uh and the white house
put out propaganda today that's what
that's what we're gonna do but obviously
the entry fee two watch this show shows
free contents free efforts free
liking is all we ask all you got to do
is go hit that like button
if we get john what are we going to do
today today's a big show brian armstrong
exclusive interview 2k likes 2k likes i
ain't going to beg you for it i'm not
gonna continue to prod you but if we get
to 2 000 likes 2k
then
what do we give away
whatever you want i don't know should we
give away a car
a car nah we're not going to do that
who's got the phones
might give away your car uh all right if
we get to 2k likes what we'll do is
we'll select three people and you can go
into the merch store you can pick any
piece of merch and we will get it
shipped to you completely for free just
as a thank you for watching this show so
let's get to 2k likes and get it going
today this morning the white house put
out a study
and that study claims
that there's a new estimate
the 400 wealthiest american families
only paid on average a federal tax rate
of 8.2 percent
now that's much lower tax rate than
historically we've heard
and so immediately that headline the 400
wealthiest american families only paid
eight percent federal tax
jumps off the page people say how's that
possible so
let's dig into the report first first in
the abstract kind of the summary of it
they say that they estimate the average
federal income tax rate paid by american
its 400 wealthiest families using a
relatively comprehensive measure
relatively comprehensive measure keep
that in mind that'll be important later
of their income that includes income
from also unsold stock we do so using
publicly available statistics yeah data
whatever we estimate an average federal
income tax rate of 8.2 percent for the
period of 2010 to 2018 they also present
sensitivity analysis that yield
estimates in the six to 12 percent range
and they then proposals mitigate two key
contributors to the low estimated rate
including preferential tax rates on
capital gains and dividend income and
wealthy families ability to avoid paying
income tax on capital gains through a
provision known as stepped-up basis so
essentially what we have here is they
went they did a study
they claimed that they used relatively
comprehensive measure of income
and
the 400 wealthiest families paid 8.2
percent okay so far no red flags no
danger we are ready to rock and roll
next
piece
is when an american earns a dollar of
wages that dollar is taxed immediately
at ordinary tax income so we're starting
to get in some of the description here
but when they gain a dollar because
their stocks increase in value that
dollar is taxed at a low preferred rate
or never at all
and so what they're getting at here is
that the most common estimates of tax
rates do not fully capture the value of
this tax benefit because they use an
incomplete measure of income okay
getting a little weird
next
is how the wealthy enjoy low income tax
so now that here's an explanation
preferred rates on an incomplete measure
of income
this is a study that was put up by the
white house that was done by economist
that says the wealthy pay low income tax
rates year after year for two primary
reasons
according to the white house and these
economists they say first much of their
income is taxed at preferred rates in
particular income from dividends and
from stock sales is taxed at a maximum
of 20 percent
which is much lower than the maximum 37
percent ordinary rate that applies to
other income
second the wealthy can choose when their
capital gains income appears on their
income tax returns and never and even
prevent it from ever appearing if a
wealthy investor never sells stock that
is increased in value those investment
gains are wiped out for income tax
purposes when those assets are passed on
to their hairs under a provision known
as stepped-up basis
and i think we have one last
piece of this here
is the study also
again they keep using this term
comprehensive measure of income
a preferred tax rate on income from
stock sales realized capital gains
income and from dividends feature
prominently in commonly cited tax rates
as well as in our analysis an important
feature of our analysis that is less
common in existing estimates of tax
rates is that we include untaxed capital
gains income in our more comprehensive
income measure as they accrue all right
that's all what they said
i'm going to walk you through a couple
of different things here first of all if
i ask you what is the tax rate that
somebody pays and you tell me that they
made a hundred dollars
and they paid ten dollars in taxes that
would estimate or that would be a ten
percent tax rate right made a hundred
dollars in income i paid ten dollars uh
in taxes i paid a 10 tax rate if i then
go and say ah i don't actually think you
made a hundred dollars
instead i think you made
i don't know
500 dollars and now that five hundred
dollars you actually only paid ten
dollars in taxes so you didn't pay ten
percent tax you actually only paid two
percent tax
well
what
if i actually made a hundred dollars
originally that's what i reported to the
government and i paid ten dollars of
taxes on i had a ten percent tax rate to
use easy numbers and the government said
yep that's what you owed us yoda's ten
percent
then i actually paid
ten percent
then go and inflate
the income based on other measurements
that are not currently how income is
defined
of course you're going to be able to say
people pay a lower rate this is this is
classic manipulation of data which is
the taxes that are owed based on the
current tax system
end up being one number and what this
study does is it goes and it says oh
actually we're going to drastically
expand the definition of income and we
are going to drastically expand the
denominator in this equation and
therefore we're going to artificially
and manipulate that number down and then
we're going to put a big headline on a
report and we're going to publish it on
the white house website it's propaganda
that's what this is this is propaganda
coming from the white house now
there's propaganda that works in both
ways
some administrations issue this stuff
and they say hey people don't need to
pay as much tax we should actually issue
tax cuts other administrations like the
current one issue reports that say hey
we should tax people more so it's both
political parties engage in this stuff
it just so happens that the current
administration is trying to advocate for
higher taxes not lower taxes so the
important parts are
one
nobody is claiming including these folks
that the actual rate that was paid was
8.2 by the 400 wealthiest american
families
what they're actually saying is that if
we count differently
and then we apply what they paid so if
we take a
a hypothetical amount of income
and then we apply what they actually did
pay then it would be 8.2 percent
but
if we actually said no we're going to
count differently the income and then we
applied the tax rates they would pay way
more than 8.2 percent so what you
essentially have is you're taking a fact
which is what they paid in aggregate
dollar amount and then you're creating a
hypothetical income number and you're
trying to apply a fact to a hypothetical
to manipulate data to say what you want
it's intellectually dishonest
now on top of that
what this explicitly calls out first is
economists people who are academics they
no longer seek truth they no longer seek
the understanding of markets they
actually no longer even seek accuracy
they merely have become political pawns
for both sides of the aisle
there are economists that are
manipulating data to tell us that
there's very high levels of inflation
and there's economists that are
manipulating data to tell us that we
shouldn't worry about inflation at all
there's economists that are manipulating
data to tell us that we should tax
everyone way more tax the rich burn it
all down take all their money
and then there's economists that are
manipulating data to say we should tax
nobody and if the federal government has
a spending problem
the truth is probably somewhere in
between
but what we can no longer rely on is we
cannot rely on economist
because what we have shown over and over
and over again is the data collection
the data sets and the methodology that
goes into these types of analysis are
completely flawed they fail any actual
pressure or logic
how is it that you can take what people
actually paid which the government has
said yes you paid me the right amount
and then hypothetically inflate the
amount of income that you wished that
you could count and then compare the two
things and then say oh by the way they
only paid 8.2 percent because if you go
look at the tax returns the actual
documents of what those families paid
it's not 8.2 percent it's something much
higher now we can debate whether they
should be paid more
or less than what they actually paid
that's fine that's a that's a fair
debate and one that is is playing out
right now but what you can't say is that
they actually paid 8.2 percent it's
intellectually dishonest and i would
even go as far as to say it's inaccurate
now on top of that
this all comes down to something called
unrealized capital gains the idea of
unrealized capital gains is if i take a
hundred dollars and i buy a stock and
that stock appreciates and let's say
that stock goes from 100
all the way up to 500 in value now so i
put 100 in the system as an investment
that company
used that money to go and create jobs to
build products and services to pay their
employees to pay taxes to the government
etc
they then
are able to increase the value of their
business
and my share in the company is not worth
a hundred dollars anymore it's not worth
500. i'm a great investor
i have not yet sold that stock
and so what unrealized capital gains
means
is that i went from a hundred dollars to
500 i have 400
of unrealized gain
if i was to sell the 500
stock now
i would take back my 100 principal plus
400
of gains that would be realized capital
gains and i would be taxed when i sell
that stock
so what essentially they are trying to
get at here is they are trying to count
unrealized capital gains
as income now there's an entire push in
certain parts of the economy by certain
economists by certain politicians
certain social groups etc to tax
unrealized gains
now to give you a sense of how idiotic
and stupid this would be
the u.s stock market the s p 500 is up
30 plus percent in the last 12 months
that means that for every dollar
that has been invested over the last
year
every single person in the stock market
owes
30
percent give or take depending on how
you count short-term long-term capital
gains 20
is long-term something higher is
short-term i avoid short-term capital
gains
and so now all of a sudden if it's up 30
percent
that means that every single american
who owns a us-based stock would have to
sell some of their stocks
to pay for the gains that the stock
market gave them you would
disincentivize people from investing
it would be a complete
new addition of friction
on top of that
you start to look at things like
every single american who owns a home
home prices are up double digits over
the last 12 months
every single american if you owned a
home and it was two hundred thousand 000
and let's say your home is now worth 300
000
you don't know that for sure but it kind
of sort of looks like that based on
comps in your area
if your house appreciated 50 in the last
year and you owe taxes
from a 200 to 300 000 home value it's a
hundred thousand dollars in unrealized
gains
that means you owe 30 000
plus or minus depending on the exact tax
rate you get hit with
where are americans going to come up
with that
90 of americans don't even have enough
money to pay for retirement
let alone every year to pay the
government because the home that they
purchased went up in value
unrealized capital gains is about the
dumbest economic
idea
that we've ever seen
because also we never hear about
unrealized capital losses
if i was to buy that stock at 100
and rather than it go to 500
instead it actually went down by 50
percent and that hundred dollar stock
was now only worth 50
nobody's talking about giving me 50
in losses
if i don't sell the stock
so how is it that the unrealized capital
gains
is in the crosshairs
but we don't want to give the same
treatment to the people who make an
investment and if they lose money in an
unrealized basis they get the benefit of
the loss
it's because this has nothing to do
with fairness it has nothing to do
with trying to actually create an
economic system that incentivize
investment in innovation job creation r
d etc
no what it's about
is simply punishing success
condemning success
taking from those people who have done
something
eighty percent of u.s millionaires
inherited zero dollars
they built
their wealth they did not inherit it
eighty percent
33 percent of millionaires in america
never made more than a hundred thousand
dollars
so now those people who have been
investing their entire lives we're gonna
punish them for being disciplined for
spending less than they make staying out
of debt buying long-term assets and
holding them you completely
disincentivize capitalism
and we have example after example after
example in history of socialism
absolutely not working
now on top of this
not only do we never hear about
unrealized losses
and not only do we never want to have
the conversation about now every
american homeowner has to pay unrealized
capital gains on their house
or on their stocks or in their
retirement accounts
on top of that are we just going to have
national crash the stock market day
is that what we're actually advocating
for
is the tens of millions of americans who
are invested in the u.s stock market
when it comes to paying unrealized
capital gains we're all gonna go to the
stock market take a couple of shots of
liquor and then just pull on the wheel
and hope to god that when we all sell at
the same time to be able to get money to
pay the tax man that we don't crash the
stock market
this is insanity
and frankly
it's disappointing to see
the white house publish something like
this
that they know to be inaccurate
nobody there that's why they're so
explicitly calling it out
because they understand that what
they're saying is not true and so they
have to immediately explain how they get
to that number
and so they're using unrealized capital
gains
now my favorite part about this also is
this the idea of stepped-up basis
and so let's say that john and i
were not brothers
brothers in arms and brothers in blood
instead
john and i
were father and son
and i was an amazing investor and i
bought all these assets through my life
and towards the end of my life
i went ahead and i wrote a will and in
my will i said you know what
my kid is in a deadbeat he's actually
pretty smart
i want when i die him to make the
decisions as to what happened to my
assets
this is a pretty normal activity for
almost everyone in the world what
happens when i die
now when i die let's say that i had a
piece of real estate that piece of real
estate i bought for a hundred dollars it
is now appreciated over the la my
lifetime and it's worth a thousand
dollars
when john inherits that piece of real
estate
rather than the cost basis of the real
estate being a hundred dollars
the cost basis now goes up to a thousand
dollars he inherited it and so there's a
step up
in the cost basis john's cost basis is a
thousand dollars my cost basis was a
hundred
now the reason why we do that is because
if john ever goes to sell the real
estate
john and let's say now it's worth
uh fifteen hundred dollars john will pay
taxes on his 500 dollar gain from a
thousand to 500 uh to 1500
he still has to pay taxes when he sells
it at a profit
but that step up basis is one thing that
we are talking about here
now if you read this you would be
remiss
to think
are wealthy people
so worried about taxes that their tax
strategy
is to die
is that really the tax strategy that
we're claiming wealthy people are taking
is that i want to save money from paying
taxes so badly
that i'll die
it's not like wealthy people are off in
the corner committing suicide to prevent
paying taxes
it's not like they're telling hey john
you want this real estate kill me dog
like i gotcha
no
death
is inevitable
and so we can argue and debate over how
we treat
assets should john
have to pay taxes based on a gain from a
hundred dollars to fifteen hundred
dollars or should john have to pay taxes
from the thousand dollar stepped up
basis to fifteen hundred dollars
those debates are fine but to insinuate
that
older people wealthy people are
literally planning death in order to
avoid paying taxes is ridiculous
and so when you start to look at
the stepped-up basis
what you have to ask yourself is
are we trying to punish dead people
or are we trying to incentivize
those that are inheriting the assets
to continue to invest
in whatever the assets are the entire
point of the tax system is it serves as
a carrot
and a stick
you can manipulate the tax code to
incentivize investment
puerto rico is a great example i've got
many friends who moved to puerto rico
why they're not puerto rican it's not
because they went on vacation there and
they figured it was beautiful and they
were like i want to live here
no they started to look at it because
there was tax incentives there were
lower tax rates there explicitly put in
place because they wanted to incentivize
people to move there so that they would
invest in the local economy
they would create jobs they would employ
people they would buy things they would
invest in the real estate they would end
up building up that economy
so tax incentives can work as a carrot
or they can work as a stick and you can
use them to ensure that people are doing
the things that you want them to do
this is true around the world this is
not just a us-based thing
but what you can't do
is we can't sit by and allow people to
manipulate data in a way that literally
states something that is not true if you
go and you look at the actual taxes
that actual tax
returns
the 400 wealthiest american families
didn't pay 8.2 percent something higher
i don't know what it is i haven't seen
the tax records but based on this
methodology
it's not possible because the 8.2
percent
is being used
on unrealized capital gains
now on top of that i don't think that we
have the political will nor do i
actually believe the people who are
saying that they're going to institute
unrealized capital gains taxes
because guess what
the multi-millionaires
who
run the current administration
joe biden estimated to be worth 10 plus
million dollars kamala harris estimated
to be worth millions of dollars
and also
many of the other elected congressmen
and senators
they're not going to sell their stock
every year to pay the tax either
this isn't about the little guy and it's
not about the big guy it's about simply
understanding
if you want to incentivize investment
incentivize economic prosperity and
incentivize innovation
you can't have a system
that punishes people for successfully
investing
instead
you're better off saying to people and
this is my main message
throughout this entire report
it says wealthy people wealthy people
wealthy people
they don't have a special tax code
these rules apply
to the richest person
and to the poorest person in america
they are the rules
the difference is not the amount of
wealth they have
the difference is
information
and sometimes
the wealthiest or the poorest
actually
know the information themselves they've
educated themselves on the tax code
and other times they've hired somebody
to do that
but the tax code is not there's not two
tax codes
rich people cut rules poor people rules
middle class rules that's not how it
works
instead the rules are there for everyone
so rather than complaining about this
rather than sitting there and pointing
at the people who have taken the time or
used the resources to get the
information and figure out how to use
this to their advantage
instead what we should be telling people
is you can do this too
you can use these exact same rules
and you can use the tax code
in order to benefit from it
there's no difference between jeff bezos
buying stock
and holding it as it goes up and not
paying tax on that wealth creation
then you doing the same thing you can go
to sofi.com
you can buy a stock and if it goes up
500 percent you won't pay taxes either
until it is sold
that's the tax code
so it's not a oh the wealthy people are
doing something nefarious or malicious
it's just that we have a financial
education gap in this country
they are educated on this stuff and
everyone else isn't
and so rather than trying to take from
the people who figured it out
the entire point of this show is that we
should go and we should ask every single
person who figured it out how'd you do
it
tell me what to do explain to me how can
i use investing to build a life of
wealth happiness and financial security
rather than
saying to them oh you shouldn't have
that
every single person watching this right
now these rules you can use to your
advantage too invest
that's how they create wealth they
invest
there's nobody who has built
generational wealth that got it through
a salary
invest and if you invest you can
leverage parts of the rules to your
advantage where you can compound wealth
through your life and not have to pay
material percentages of it to
taxes
there's no different rule set you just
gotta learn the rules right john
yeah you said a lot of stuff wow um uh a
few notes on what you just said if you
want to put me in your will totally fine
with that there's there's no problem my
end but uh yeah look they've been
actually talking about taxing unrealized
gains at the end of the year for pretty
much this whole year so it's interesting
that they don't um and then look i agree
this is propaganda at the white house
it's frankly sad that they're trying to
spin this narrative
uh but yeah of course the wealthy owned
assets that's how most of them got
wealthy they're playing by the rules
that have already been set um through
the tax code they're just doing it
because they're smart
uh and look if you want to change the
rules that's fine make sure to change it
for everyone um and look the the goal of
this should be to educate the masses
right that is the biggest problem is a
lot of people are not educated and they
don't know these rules they aren't
invested what is it 45 of americans have
no investable assets that's ridiculous
that was the whole point why we kind of
created this show was to be able to
create um financial education for other
people
and if you ask the government they'll
say the wealthy tax rate is 8.2 percent
i'm sure if you ask those individuals
they can say their tax rate is probably
40 to 60 some higher some lower and
they're both gonna be right depending on
how they spin the narrative
it's true the the part to me that i
think people
don't yet understand
is
this is not new this has been going on
for centuries
and
the tax code
is super complex there's all kinds of
different rules etc
but again the idea is to incentivize
activity right and the part that i think
you're bringing up here
which is really really good
if you ask the government they say 8.2
percent if you literally look at the tax
returns or you talk to the people
they'll say i paid way more than eight
points they they'd be happy to pay 8.2
right
and so when we look at it
the capital gains the whole idea of
realized versus unrealized capital gains
i think it sounds good right i literally
saw a bunch of people tweeting this
report from the white house and they
were
all over the place hashtag tax the rich
it sounds awesome tax the rich
but the problem
with simply saying tax the rich
is that if again just like the rule book
today applies to everyone
it's going to apply to everyone else as
well and so now all of a sudden
unrealized capital gains
is part of your income
every single american that was invested
in the stock market
over the last 12 months
owes
ten percent
of their total stock market
portfolio
that's what it would come down to if i
put a hundred dollars in the s p is up
35
and if i owe around 30 percent
i owe
out of 130
i'm gonna owe somewhere around
10 to 13 in taxes
if you're gonna tax the unrealized gains
make sure to give me a tax deduction for
the losses
of course
but nobody talks about that they're
never going to do that though that's the
problem well because the rules only
apply if you're successful right
but
successful is not a measure of wealth
it's simply every single person who
holds a stock
so are we now going to go and we're
going to say to the 18 year old kid
who's just starting out hey i know you
just bought your first 20 worth of stock
and you know what the stock doubled
congratulations now you owe us
20 or 30 percent depending on long or
short term gains you owe us
let's say 30 is an average number
you owe us 30
on that so you're 20 that just turned
into 40.
sorry buddy give me six bucks
so now that kid who's just starting out
investing who thought that they had 40
and they thought that they could
compound that at eight percent year over
year over year over year
no
because guess what if you take 20 or 30
percent
if the compound growth
let's let's just easing let's say the
compound growth in your portfolio was 10
a year
but now you have to pay unrealized
capital gains and again these are
generalized numbers
but now all of a sudden you have to pay
let's say 30 unrealized capital gains
your return goes from 10
to 7.
go do compound math
on seven percent annualized returns
for forty years versus ten
it will literally be the difference of
millions of dollars for some people
why
we should incentivize as much investment
as much innovation as much r d as much
job creation in this country as we
possibly can because that's how you win
every country in the world that became
overreaching
and try to take from those who had
something
over and over and over and over again
what they end up doing is they end up
disincentivizing
innovation and success
i want any person in the world to come
to this country
and be able to build whatever they want
the fact that 80 percent of millionaires
in america didn't inherit anything i
hope the number goes to 99
right i literally want anybody in the
world to want to come here and be able
to build that life let's not make it
harder for them let's make it easier and
sure you know what there's a couple of
rich people along the way they're going
to benefit from it
who cares it's not about trying to
punish 400 families
that's what we're targeting here 400
families is in this study
what about the hundred plus million
americans who have no clue how they're
going to retire
what about the people
who lost their jobs over the last 12
months
what about the 11 million open rolls
right now
that nobody is able to actually figure
out how to fill
what about the bottom 45 percent of
americans who own no investable assets
but are now dealing with minimum 5.3
inflation
and their local bank will pay them 0.03
percent
in their bank account
maybe what we should be telling people
is not if you make money through
investments we're gonna take it
and instead we should be saying to the
bottom 45 percent of americans if today
you have no investments and you begin
investing we won't tax you for a decade
we'll help you get into the market we'll
actually let compounding work for you
and those 45 percent of americans with
no investments we will do everything we
possibly can to incentivize you to
invest
that's how you actually make
an inflection point
not hey
if you put money in the stock market and
the stock market goes up 30
we're coming for the cash i don't give
financial advice ever pretty much uh but
this is definitely financial advice go
get educated on your tax system go get
educated on different investment styles
and go get invested sofi.com is a great
place to do that but look
you can't
you can't take advantage of the rules if
you don't know the rules you can't be in
the game if you're sitting on the
sidelines go get educated about these
different rules and what other people
are doing to utilize them and take
advantage of them they are available to
you as well and then go get invested
there's a reason i put get educated
before just go get invested because you
can put yourself in a better situation
if you know what you're optimizing for
and what your goal is
all right
that's all i got i'm off my soapbox it
really just upsets me when
we have things
that are obviously condemning success
rather than simply saying
let's go help the majority of folks
who need to get this information let's
tell them how to do it that's what we
should be doing what are you laughing
about i'm often if you put out a study
with numbers in it and the first thing
you have to do is basically explain how
you got to that number you know that it
is a ridiculous figure and you're trying
to basically sway a narrative to a
certain way it's it's ridiculous
the title
the title of the piece
what is the average federal income
individual income tax rate on the
wealthiest americans
that's the title on the white house blog
it's not the average federal income tax
rate
that's not what they paid
again i'm not saying they shouldn't pay
more i'm not saying they shouldn't pay
less or i'm not saying that the amount
they paid is right but what i am saying
is that if you present this as the
average federal income tax rate
you should go look at their tax returns
and tell us what the actual numbers are
not what you think they should be which
is exactly what this does they should
release the names and have these people
be able to um
not redact but be able to say look no
this is what i paid not not dollar wise
just percent wise oh there's some
billionaires out there that they're
gonna come out they're gonna be like i
pay percent
yeah you want me pay-per-view how do i
sign up for that right what i forget the
numbers of steve ballmer but steve
ballmer we like calculated his tax rate
or something he paid like 15 percent
right which again there's gonna be
people who say oh my god how can he only
pay 15 he should pay more that's a whole
different conversation it's just that
let's use him as the example at 15 i
think direction was correct somebody
will remember exactly what the number
was but let's say he paid 15
there's a big difference between 8 and
15 almost double the number and so the
point is again we hammer this point home
over and over and over again you can't
make good decisions with bad data you
can't use this as the number if it's not
the real number because we don't
actually know
we have no way of knowing and that's the
problem in my opinion all right
are you good i'm i'm good you got
everything out you need to get out yeah
i just look and people are going to be
pissed whatever the the reason why
people get mad about this stuff is
because ultimately most of the folks who
are yelling and screaming tax the rich
uh unfortunately a lot of times it's
because they feel like they can't get
ahead right they feel like uh i i don't
know what to do i'm falling behind uh
and therefore the the uh psychological
like relief of screaming and lashing out
and saying like take from them
is uh in their opinion um the the best
thing to do but instead i think that
rather than have a kind of pessimistic
view of the world and to say that's the
only solution i take a more optimistic
view of the world which is if we can
educate those people they can benefit
from the exact same rules yeah and i
like how we're kind of calling them out
on their [ __ ] a little bit uh
because most people don't and if you
don't it will just continue to spin the
narrative and then if you say it enough
times over and over it just becomes true
somehow um and unfortunately that's the
word we live in today there's a lot of
people who i already saw they were
writing articles i said these types of
headlines off from the white house and
stuff it's literally just meant to
elicit bombastic headlines from the
media like there's some
unfortunately usually a young person who
doesn't understand all the calculations
doesn't understand how realized and
realized capital gains works etc and
what do they do they just see it bam
here it comes they write the article
push it it's out on the website next
thing you know somebody reads it and
they say x y z publication said that
this is true and that's how narratives
take hold so it's it's absolutely crazy
all right you ready to move on
how are we at we're at 800 likes can we
get some love around here there's nobody
else talking about this stuff anywhere
on the internet let's go when that
article came out this morning now huh
that article came out this morning
that article came out this morning yeah
the 23rd exactly
the um
are people all upset people are saying
that uh
uh
people will disagree with us of course
of course people are going to disagree
with us that's the whole point that's
where debate comes from it's okay that
people disagree we want people to
disagree if you disagree leave a comment
smash the likes let's go all right fed
federal reserve is pushing ahead with a
study on whether to implement its own
digital currency and they're going to
release the paper shortly uh according
to jerome powell uh establishing a
digital dollar has been on the fed's
radar for more than a year uh announced
in may it's launching a deeper
examination and uh jerome powell
recently said that the test for cbdc is
quote are there clear and tangible
benefits that outweigh any cost and risk
which
i think is a pretty fair way to evaluate
it okay we have we understand central
bank digital currencies for those that
don't know what that is it's essentially
a digital token so if you think dollars
used to be in physical form pieces of
paper
uh we then moved to today uh when you go
to the atm or you look on your bank
account uh online uh dollars are not in
paper form it's not like the bank's just
got literally trillions of dollars
sitting there instead what they have is
they have electronic q-sips that are in
centralized databases so inside of
jpmorgan they kind of keep track of all
the different things inside bank of
america they keep track of it all on a
centralized ledger inside their business
inside of uh you know wells fargo or
first republic or whatever then when
these banks want to actually transact
with each other what they are doing is
not actually sending the dollars around
what they're actually doing is they are
simply just settling their books with
each other which is a little bit
different so a little nuance in terms of
how that works but it's called
electronic qsip q-sip c-u-s-i-p
and it's basically a file format that
uses inside the centralized databases
now what they're talking about the
central bank digital currency is
evolving or improving that technology to
go from electronic q-sips to digital
tokens
it's still a dollar it's still the same
monetary policy nothing changes it's
just a technology change
and so if you're evaluating creating a
certain type of technology if you say
hey are there clear and tangible
benefits that outweigh any costs and
risks i think that's a pretty good way
to evaluate it now boston fed is
undertaking a multi-year research with
the mit to explore the technology that
could be used for the cbdc and the first
phase of the research is expected soon
uh there's a whole bunch of other
countries who have been playing around
in this
i'm trying to figure it out uh we have a
quote i think from jerome powell uh that
is uh uh i think a pretty you know
rational thought process here he says we
think it's really important that central
bank maintain a stable currency and
payment systems for the public's benefit
that's one of our jobs completely agree
right i think he he nailed it here um
and so obviously you wouldn't want to
introduce a central bank digital
currency if you weren't going to have a
stable payment system or something like
that if you thought you could make it
more stable or more dependable than you
absolutely would want to introduce it
and when you look at we've got a map
on a number of these countries
this map shows what other countries are
doing so about five countries around the
world have launched central bank digital
currencies even if they're on a small
scale there's 14 pilots 16 of them have
developed them uh 32 are researching
them 10 started it but now are inactive
and then two canceled uh their plans for
central bank digital currency so kind of
all over the map shout out to atlantic
council for that uh for that map right
there but yeah look the us is almost
falling behind on this and i understand
drone power kind of went back and forth
with
should we be more aggressive about this
or do we want to sit back see what
happens study it a little bit more and
make sure we do it right uh i agree that
it's more important to
do it right than do it first right so
other countries have already launched
this we've seen this in japan in the uk
all these other places but we are
falling behind um the four largest
central banks the federal reserve
european central bank bank of japan and
bank of england the us is the furthest
behind on the research and the uh
deployment of a central bank digital
currency
we got to hurry up i see i see a couple
of people asking about uh why they were
canceled why people started doing it and
then canceled it i'm not sure we can
actually research why they uh why they
ended up canceling it but
two of them did and then the other piece
of this too i think is really
interesting uh so my personal opinion is
that every single fiat currency is going
to end up being digitized right so we'll
have a digital dollar digital one
digital euro digital yen digital peso et
cetera
and
it's less about changing the monetary
policy it's less about changing the
national structure of the currency it's
much much more about
changing the technology and so if i said
to you hey uh your currency is
susceptible to hours of operation you
have to have if you want to send large
amounts a wire you have to call in by
certain time every day then it's going
to take a day to settle maybe two days
depending where you're sending it the
fee structure et cetera if all of a
sudden i can put that in a much more
advantageous position say you still have
dollars but you're able to send it
instantaneously cheaper you have access
24 7 365
and the settlement time is uh is much
faster then i think most people say hey
look i would love to uh to go ahead and
do that
it's just going to take some time i
think for people to kind of wrap their
heads around it the other question that
comes is how are they going to build the
technology is the federal reserve do
they have the technical
capabilities and appetite right going
and building this is pretty difficult so
do they have the capabilities and the
appetite to build it or will they simply
partner with a private company or or
some sort of technology provider whether
it is to build internally a brand new
cbdc uh or would they just somehow kind
of partner with one of the existing
stablecoin providers and say hey look
we're going to go ahead and we're going
to use this we're going to you know
choose you as the as the player here
yeah i agree this technology is very new
right so in may 2020 about 35 countries
were kind of exploring it uh and think
about deploying it and all of that now
81 countries that represent over 90 of
the global global gdp have
gotten their gotten their feet wet right
in this situation um but i think i'm
curious your thoughts i think actually
developing these currencies will do
more control for the government and less
privacy for the actual individuals i
completely agree that's the downside in
my opinion is control
right now let's say that i want to see
what's in your bank account uh and i'm
the government i have to go i have to
get like a fisa court or some sort of
order either freeze your assets look at
them so they say well yeah
uh but in terms of the um
uh stable coins they'd be able to see
everything and on top of that the other
piece of it uh ends up being that
there's a um
a really uh
uh big issue around the privacy and the
financial surveillance so what happens
if all of a sudden the rails say hey
john uh you drank too much coffee today
you can't buy that soda you gotta buy
water
okay that's like pretty aggressive
extreme you know example what if all of
a sudden they say hey john uh actually
you know what you can't ride the uh uh
bus today you gotta walk
you even walked enough well someone said
something relative like this in the chat
is what if they start deciding who you
are allowed and not allowed to do
business with
it's possible again i'm not i'm not
saying that they're going to go do that
right away but the fact that they have
the ability you can just see like it it
is an incentive to kind of continue to
creep into those worlds uh and that's
scary stuff right you think we create a
uh central bank digital currency within
the next five years
i think that there
will be a mass global adoption of stable
coins within the next you know three
years already you could argue that
people are starting to adopt it now um
the question is going to be does the
united states create an official uh fed
coin right or central bank digital
currency i think they will end up
creating one
five years uh i think they will have
decided to do it they'll say yes we're
gonna do this the big question is how
are they technically gonna do it can
they build it themselves i don't know if
they can get it built and launched in a
you know three to five year period uh
but if they went they just partnered
with somebody who already built it then
it's possible so so i think that the
obstacle is less about the decision to
go ahead and do this i think the
obstacle is more about the technical uh
kind of execution and actually getting
it to the point where remember you not
only have to serve the 330 million
americans you know uh that use the
dollar as their uh
reserve currency get paid in it saving
it etc but it's the global reserve
currency so you have to be able to use
the dollar globally with all sorts of
different technical complexities that
are added so it look it's a very very
difficult technical problem
that i just don't think they could
create in you know six months and this
would also take a lot of time to
implement right so you can't just one
day say hey look none of your usd notes
are valid anymore you have to bring them
by back by this state and then we will
change them for a digital currency it's
going to take years and years and years
of um adoption and kind of the rollout
phases and i'm sure they do it in
incremental phases i like how they're
looking at it i like how they are taking
their time and analyzing each situation
because there's nothing worse than
making the wrong decision here yeah i
think that being uh taking your time is
very prudent in not making a mistake the
question is should they be accelerating
the testing and then you can always
choose not to launch it kind of widely
um but we'll see all right we are going
to very quickly go to break it we're
going to come back with uh brian
armstrong a couple of things one what
are we at on uh likes we're at a
thousand likes let's go if we get to 2k
likes
what do we say we're gonna do
giveaway merch three people first three
people
free stuff two steps
entry fee free content for everyone but
you gotta like the video that's what we
need from you let's go let's do it
second thing is this interview was
pre-recorded we recorded it yesterday
afternoon uh a whole bunch of different
reasons why we did that uh but i believe
that it is fully unedited minus there
was one moment i think where uh brian's
cat jumped in the video
uh we almost left it in but then i had
told him i like in the middle had said
hey we're gonna edit that out uh and the
reason why uh we edited it out is uh
just to make it kind of easier but all
of the content from beginning to end
minus the cat incident uh right there is
uh is here so we haven't done anything
to the video etc but i think guys will
really like it so we're gonna go to
commercial we'll be right back with uh
coinbase ceo brian armstrong and uh we
will be ready to rock and roll i hope
you guys enjoyed this
[Music]
the best business show is exactly that
it's the best why because it's the show
that me joe and john wish that we had
when we were learning
now we've got the best partner which is
so fun so far is one of those platforms
that just hits different why
sofi is basically a super app it does
everything from allowing you to have
budgeting and saving tools to helping
you refinance student loans and they
help you invest in everything from etfs
to individual stocks pre-ipo companies
and cryptocurrencies use the link below
or go to
sofi.com
to sign up for a sofi active invest
account and you can win up to a thousand
dollars
when you want anything to help you
create a better financial life so far
likely can do it if you're looking for a
platform where you can go and do all in
one sofa is that place we're really
excited to partner with sofi on this
because we think they've built an
amazing product and we think that the
product and features that they have will
help simplify the lives of our audience
go check them out today at sofi.com pomp
and let us know what you think sofi.com
pomp that's where we'll be
[Music]
all right guys bang bang i've got brian
here with me thank you so much for doing
this man
thanks for having me this is great
absolutely let's just start off with uh
a reminder to folks about coinbase the
business in terms of what your mission
uh is as a business and then what the
product suite looks like today
yeah sure our mission is to create more
economic freedom in the world and so you
know i think coin you know crypto is
probably the best technology out there
to do that right now i got really
excited about economic freedom a long
time ago i read about it and it's kind
of this composite metric that looks at
all the countries of the world and it
tries to look at things like how easy is
it to start a business is the currency
stable
is there free trade
is there corruption in bribery and the
economy and stuff like that and are
property rights enforced basically
and when i first read the bitcoin white
paper back in 2010 that was kind of one
of the first thoughts that went through
my head was wow this might be this key
to unlocking more economic freedom
globally and going and creating better
financial infrastructure for the world
so that's the mission of coinbase and
we have a whole bunch of products with
different customer segments so we have
retail customers institutions and
developers on the retail side we've got
our app out there that has you know
about 60 million verified users and
helping people buy and sell crypto and
then increasingly use it for more and
more different things
and then on the institutional side we've
got about 9 000 institutions signed up
who are increasingly coming into crypto
storing more and more of their assets
within crypto which is great because
actually a lot of the money in the world
majority of the money in the world is
tied up in institutions not in retail
and then um lastly developers so we want
to help this whole crypto economy and
ecosystem grow
so we're building things like coinbase
cloud which is
aws for crypto we're kind of
externalizing all the services that
we've built internally um like how to
integrate these blockchains and custody
and trade and everything and make it so
anybody can build their business on top
of those
and then we're doing things like
coinbase asset hub trying to make it
easier for people to create their own
tokens and get them listed on coinbase
and maybe even eventually create dows
and and raise money um
and just change the whole way that
capital formation happens with with all
these crypto startups that are getting
built so those are our three customer
segments and that's our mission
economic freedom is a really interesting
topic and most people i think uh they
talk about the assets they talk about
the technology but they kind of lose the
plot as to what the potential impact on
a global stage can be
what is it about the economic freedom
that you think kind of caught your
attention or really kind of drew you to
that specific idea that measurement
the best business show is exactly that
it's the best why because it's the show
that me joe and john wish that we had
when we were learning
now we've got the best partner which is
so fun so far is one of those platforms
that just hits different why sofi is
basically a super app it does everything
from allowing you to have budgeting and
saving tools to helping you refinance
student loans and they help you invest
in everything from capture some of the
upside that's a very simple but very
powerful idea and arguably it's almost
sufficient to get
a huge amount of innovation and progress
happening in society so i'm very excited
about
you know how do you how do you get
better more progress happening in
society how do you bet get more
technology innovation and property
rights and economic freedom are kind of
a core foundation of that so i felt like
this might be one of those rare moments
in history where a small group of people
could take this brilliant technology
innovation bitcoin
and with the
proliferation of smartphones and the
internet
actually inject economic freedom and
property rights and good financial
infrastructure into all these countries
all over the world
um really even just from one company
doing that and that just i couldn't stop
thinking about it for you know a year
and so eventually i was like all right i
got to try creating some kind of a
prototype and that led to the origin of
coinbase
uh you made a good bet because uh that
seems to be what is occurring as as
we're watching this all uh play out here
um i should say before we have a
conversation about the public company
and uh and some of the regulatory stuff
uh i've got equity exposure to coinbase
obviously you're a shareholder in the
business and uh nothing here is
financial advice but in terms of uh
coinbase you've built a business that is
today worth tens of billions of dollars
uh and recently took the company public
any lessons learned from that process of
going public any things that have
surprised you or downsides that maybe
you didn't expect as well
um yeah you know so actually i wasn't
sure that i wanted to be a public
company ceo when i first started
coinbase because you know i'm like an
engineer product person by background um
i felt i'd read all these stories about
how once you take a company public it's
like there's kind of activist
shareholders and you have to spend you
know i talked to some public company
ceos actually and when i was trying to
figure all this out and they were some
of them told me
they spent 30 40 percent of their time
just talking with public market
investors and to me i felt like you know
this might be something that just slows
us down and how we're going to create
great products
but i realized over time that you know
there's many different ways to go public
and you can actually create this in a
way that's very beneficial to the
company so
just to give you a couple examples that
are
like very positive reasons why why to do
it and why part of why we did it
you know one of them is that um it's a
huge legitimizing force for not only
your own company but for the industry
so for instance once we became a public
company a whole bunch of fortune 500
companies started you know being more
comfortable working with us on
especially on the institutional side of
our business and on the developer side
but it's um
i didn't realize i'd appreciate this
until we went public like the the level
of um legitimacy that it actually
applies to the company now on top of
that it gives a whole bunch of liquidity
to the early investors and the employees
i think over a million
sorry over a thousand millionaires were
created at coinbase when we went public
which was an incredible statistic so
that was just
hugely emotional and life-changing for
um so many people and it turned out to
be for me as well
and then it gives us now that our stock
has this kind of liquidity to it it's
given us a liquid currency to go out and
do more international expansion and
things like that it also by the way it's
much easier to raise money as a public
company um you know we've recently
raised um like two billion dollars in
debt and the whole thing took about one
week um i actually didn't have to go to
a single meeting for that um although
our cfo did a whole bunch of meetings so
my hat goes out my hat's off to her but
um yeah there's some definite advantages
of being a public company i've so far
i've been really enjoying it i'm
planning to uh keep doing it for a long
long time and i i'll give a plug to the
direct listing we did a direct listing
instead of a traditional ipo
i thought it was i thought it was great
i think we got
we got better deal terms we didn't feel
this kind of
pressure to underprice the stock for
insiders we wanted it to be a totally
fair thing we went out so anybody on day
one could uh retail institutions you
know anybody could bid and buy at any
time
and it was a fair market for everybody
um i think the direct listing was a very
positive thing so i'd recommend that to
other founders when you add in the
economic benefits the ability to a
fundraising you not having to go to the
meetings to raise capital i could see
why uh public companies is pretty
enticing uh the the elephant in the room
now is uh there seems to be a ton of
regulatory pressure both from actual
regulators and also what i'll call more
of kind of politicians or people who are
elected officials maybe let's just start
with how you view regulation obviously
as a public company ceo you're regulated
by a ton of different organizations
there's all these different rules um
like how do you view the regulation and
is there a thing as like good regulation
bad regulation or how do you look at
this
yeah so this is a very interesting
dynamic that's happening recently but
honestly it's been happening for the
entire time that coinbase has been
around nine nine years or so um it's
just kind of the intensity keeps dialing
up every year because crypto keeps
getting bigger and bigger and so
generally i view this all as a very
positive trend
um you know in the early days of
coinbase uh we made a conscious decision
we said hey we want to go out there and
work proactively with regulators and
educate them get licenses
do whatever we need to do because we
want this technology to go mainstream i
want there i want there to be a billion
people accessing an open financial
system every day through the through our
products and other other companies to
get the benefit of this technology and i
knew that
you know in in most parts of the free
world this was not going to be outlawed
or something like that at least i didn't
think that was very likely but it would
be regulated i i felt like you know
society
is is not going to just allow this to
proliferate completely unregulated so
over time we went and we got money
transmitter licenses and we started
interfacing with all of the federal
regulators and actually today coinbase
um interfaces interacts with 54
different regulators just in the united
states and we're actually in um you know
about 30 or 40 countries globally and so
we're very much a global company so we
interface with similar counterparts um
in other places so
where is this all going i mean
for a long time the crypto industry i
think has been asking for
uh clarity from the regulators out there
and saying
you know this is also new and now i
don't blame the regulators by the way
for not coming out with a ton of clarity
quickly it's such a brand new thing it
actually might have been a mistake to
come out out with it too quickly because
there are examples historically probably
of uh regulation that's come out it's
like kind of overreacted or tried to
find something too soon and this space
is evolving so quickly so you know they
kind of let it um they kind of let it
percolate we sort of shoehorned the
regulation into the existing frameworks
that are out there like like money
transmission
um but now with the advent of all this
stuff the government is starting to get
more pressure
and say hey what are we going to do
about this and so you're seeing this
kind of dance that's happening a little
bit of healthy tension i would call it
between the regulators now who are
coming out and saying all right y'all we
need to get this figured out
what's unfortunate sometimes they're
kind of doing that through enforcement
actions which um i don't think is
necessarily fair if they haven't kind of
already just
you know picked up the phone and said
hey here's our opinion on this like we
want to enforce a level playing field
across the industry everybody do this
i haven't seen that happen in some cases
which is a little frustrating they're
kind of going right to enforcement which
i think sort of sets up a negative tone
um but regardless it doesn't really
matter if it happens via enforcement or
um more internal dialogue and everything
like that we'll eventually get to a
place where we start to create legal
precedence um more of this stuff becomes
clear and the court may end up having to
eventually decide on some of these
things like which of these tokens are
securities you know um in the absence of
clarity about that topic i mean we have
we have the howie test right but the
howie test was created back in 1946 um
in a world pre-internet you know pre it
was like post right after world war ii
right so how could this howie test apply
to this brand new financial system we're
creating basically every founder and
investor and um
their highly paid lawyers are all kind
of trying to tease out like read the tea
leaves about what this could possibly
mean for their business and it's created
this kind of wide variety of
interpretations and a completely
ambiguous environment which kind of
stifles um startups and some of those
startups have decided to go abroad in
to
incorporate because of the lack of
clarity in the us so now we're sitting
here in this environment
where um you know in the absence of that
clarity coinbase went out and sort of we
created things like the crypto rating
council we created a very thorough um
digital asset listing process internally
that looked at compliance and legal and
security at cyber security and we were
actually pretty cautious about a lot of
the assets we added
um you know at the time that coinbase
had maybe 50 assets or so there was
some of our competitors had hundreds of
them right and now we have about 100
assets total that we've gotten
comfortable with many of them other ones
we've rejected and so i would expect um
this whole environment is just over the
next year or so it's going to be
a series of enforcement actions a series
of behind closed door discussions legal
precedent getting created um there will
probably be broker dealer licenses
incorporated um or i should say
operationalize you know coinbase went
out and got its brokerage license a
while back but we haven't
operationalized it because there aren't
any security tokens that our customers
want to to actually trade and so maybe
once we get that operational then other
crypto tokens will then go be pushed to
register with the sec
we actually want to make that easy as
well through a product we have called
coinbase asset hub and just make it
super simple for any asset issuer to
come you know
form a smart smart contract or however
they want to do it create a new a new
asset register it with
the sec if they need to do that in the
u.s do a reg s offering if they want to
do it abroad
so we want to try to make all this
easier
more regulated i think we're all pretty
much aligned even the regulators and and
the industry there's just going to be a
bunch of
silly headlines and you know
uncomfortable conversations as that all
plays out
so i want to try to kind of summarize
what i believe to be ural's position but
if i misspeak uh correct me is basically
look we want to play within the rules we
think regulation is generally good uh
but in some areas we don't know what the
rules are and so we're trying our best
but if we don't know what those rules
are and then all of a sudden we get told
hey don't do that it's kind of hard to
operate a business with uncertainty uh
it feels like that's one kind of talk
track or uh you know viewpoint another
is hey there's things that we think
should be allowed that feels like the
regulators are telling us they aren't
allowed and we want to have a discussion
and maybe there isn't a discussion at
the level that you want to have it or
you're not getting guidance that you're
looking for et cetera and then there's
like this third world which is basically
like hey we do things as a publicly
traded company in a regulated
environment in the united states but
like look globally and there's people
doing all kinds of different things and
so there's like a global competition
going on how much does the us want to
over regulate or regulate versus like
wide open free markets and just let
everyone go let the free market decide
is that kind of a fair characterization
of like maybe like the three points
around regulation and where you sit
that's a really great articulation of it
yeah
i do think that's really important to
remember as well the last point you said
which is that we are living in a
globally
a global free market right you know us
citizens actually
are going and using products that are
created abroad
increasingly because they're not able to
get the stuff they want in the us so
that's a risk you know i think the us
government
again we're a global company i talk to
regulators all of the world but one
thing i noticed when i go to dc is that
i think
you know 50 of the people i talk to in
dc roughly they're still thinking of
crypto as a risk they think this is
scary this is dangerous they have all
kinds of misconceptions in their head
about
the percentage of activity that's for
illicit activist purposes and all this
which is actually much smaller than most
of them realize it's probably about one
percent or less whereas the us dollar
cash is like three to four percent
illicit activity right but in their mind
they think it's like 50 illicit activity
so that's probably half the people i
meet in dc
and the other half are they realize that
this is actually a huge opportunity it's
a hugely important new industry for the
united states and every country around
the world and that they exist in a
competitive environment where the us
needs to be attracting these
entrepreneurs getting these foundational
companies built here and that frankly
you know the american citizens really
want these products and services uh tens
of millions of americans this is not a
fringe thing anymore you know coinbase
has 60 million verified users you know
um and we're just one company so there's
there's tens of millions of americans
who want to use these products and
services
they're getting a benefit from it that
they're not getting from the traditional
financial system and ultimately you know
the citizens elect our government and
the government appoints regulators and
everything like that and so
i think that if if they are too hard on
crypto basically it's going to become
politically infeasible they're not going
to have um the will of the people behind
that it's almost like um prohibition or
something like that historically like
you can't
you can't go out and like try to
criminalize something that um you know
50 million americans are doing uh you're
just gonna turn them all into criminals
but they're not gonna stop doing it and
so i think that's the maybe the one of
the big things that hasn't been um
realized yet on in dc
so i think a lot of folks uh who are
listening to this hear about regulation
they feel that there is uh some tension
between the companies in the space and
regulators both in the united states and
also internationally as well uh various
folks whether it is the sec the cftc or
some other organization i want to use
kind of the
tangible example of the lend product
that you all
had you know kind of ideated on you
wanted to create and launch
there is this now infamous um twitter
thread that you put together and put out
publicly um kind of calling attention to
the fact that you didn't think you were
going to be able to launch it and maybe
just walk us through kind of how
this process works and you know both i
think from uh if you can what you think
coinbase is kind of doing to to move
towards a a solution but also maybe from
the regular standpoint are there things
that you think like yes they're doing
this and that's actually a good thing uh
it's a fair thing to be doing and if
there's anything that they're doing that
uh that you think could be improved or
changed
yeah sure so the lend product was kind
of um an interesting example for us by
the way that the lend product is not
really material to our revenue at this
point or anything like that but it's um
it's an interesting case because
some of our you know competitors great
companies and crypto by the way um
have had a product like that out in the
market for a couple of years we've we've
seen demand from our own customers to
have it and so we decided that we wanted
to go out and put out a similar product
what was frustrating is that we
proactively went to the to the sec ahead
of time we've been telling them about
our development of this product and um
we felt like we had buy in there but as
it approached our launch date we
suddenly saw a much different stance
from them
and they came out and said we well you
can't not only do we have concerns do
not launch this and if you do we'll
we'll be suing you and they sent us a
wells notice which is kind of like a
preliminary document before you sue
somebody so the product never launched
but i was kind of frustrated by that
because i felt like
well the goal of the sec is to protect
consumers and then create a level
playing field
so
you know number one um how are they
protecting consumers in this case i
think a lot of consumers demonstrably
have wanted to earn higher yields on
their
on their savings accounts and things
like that they're not really getting
those products from the existing
financial services
so that was one open question and then
the second one was how are they creating
a level playing field because it seems
like other companies are have been able
to do this but coinbase suddenly is not
allowed to i sometimes we're we're a
more well-known company um we're a
bigger company and so we sort of get
this scrutiny that other startups don't
have by the way i kind of understand
that the sec is just one organization
they don't have time to look at every
startup but they kind of can look at the
big ones
so we were stuck in this kind of
uncomfortable position where the sec
would not tell us why they didn't why
they thought it wasn't shouldn't be
allowed
they were very close-lipped about that
i'm not sure why maybe they they didn't
want to tip their hand in some kind of
litigation or something but it just
didn't feel collaborative or uh being up
front at all
um and they were creating this unlevel
playing field in the process so at the
end of the day we sort of talked to our
lawyers about it and they felt like
what's what is our case here like should
we go you know we're being harmed should
we should we proactively sue the sec
should we uh just enter litigation with
them and try to create some kind of a
legal precedent but we felt like there's
a lot of deference given to um
regulators in the court system and we we
have frankly no desire to be engaged in
drawn out litigation with any regulator
right i consider that to be very much a
last resort
we always want to be proactive and
collaborative with people
um and so we decided not to launch the
product essentially we're going to wait
and see what the sec does in terms of
the other products that are out there
already in the market um where it's it's
not a level playing field today um i
think we want to also just focus our
efforts on maybe even more important
things happening in crypto like the
questions around which of these tokens
are securities and how is defy going to
be used um there's you know these are
the things that i guess we really want
to stand behind and sort of say these
are the benefits to the crypto community
that we want to go
make sure there's a good legal precedent
for um but i you know i when i went to
dc i reached out to the sec i tried to
get a meeting with them
they told me that they weren't meeting
with any crypto companies i was kind of
surprised by that because
there are so many different regulators
out there every single one has been
willing to meet with us and every other
branch of government by the way and scc
was really the only regulator that i was
not able to get a meeting with as a new
the first crypto public company in the
united states they weren't willing to
meet with me when i went to dc so
there's something kind of strange going
on there i wish that we would basically
all just be able to pick up the phone
and talk about this stuff it doesn't
need to be in a
combative stance and whenever i see
something like that happening that i
think is kind of um inauthentic and you
know i i i tend to talk about it
publicly i want to put this stuff out in
the in the ether so that the world can
know about it and they can make up their
own mind about
how these things should play out in
government
so i want to ask uh kind of a couple of
different perspectives from this
specific situation because i think it's
a good tangible example where people can
understand uh both your perspective and
also the regulators uh as a publicly
traded ceo uh especially one that it
just came into public markets if you
went and you talked to somebody in the
legacy finance world they would say oh
my god that is nuts to do a public
thread and talk about the sec etc how do
you think about uh risk reward in terms
of having the conversation and kind of
pushing forward to what i think
you know based from what i understand
you've said publicly and and also uh
elsewhere is um you know really trying
to work towards a solution like how do
you view that moving towards the
solution and did you evaluate any sort
of risk with kind of being more public
maybe so than than other people would
yeah so i mean
look there's no right answer here okay
so i'm not going to come out and say
that it's the right thing to do or it's
the wrong thing to do a lot of this
stuff comes down to kind of gut at the
end of the day and um the way i thought
about it was
you know
first of all twitter twitter is a funny
thing because if i had gone on to um
cnbc or something like that and said the
same thing people would have probably
thought like oh that was a healthy
debate or dialogue there's something
about twitter which um
you know
people it's a very much like a west
coast and east coast thing right so on
the east coast the the reaction to my
tweet i'd say was more negative people
were like wow how could he do that
um you know he should be going through
appropriate channels and you know wall
street journal or whatever um
and people on the west coast were like
that was the best thing i've seen you
know all year
and they were like finally somebody is
willing to just speak the truth about
what's going on behind the scenes and
put it out there in the open right
um and so i think there's just a
cultural difference that's happening
look my my i'm not naturally a combative
person i'm actually like kind of
conflict avoidant right like i my
default is to go build genuine
relationships with people just try to
work on stuff like even if we disagree
there's there's a way to make it win win
and just move forward but if somebody is
you know if they're not going to meet
with us
to even have a conversation which by the
way i still my my optimistic view is
that we can change that um we still
haven't gotten a meeting with the sec
for someone you know high up there or
gensler to talk to me personally but my
hope is that that's still on the table
um
and if i can't get that then eventually
i'm just going to go out and talk about
it publicly so that people can know
about it i think it's a form of
accountability frankly
um and that's like the way that the this
is trending in the future it's it's
going to be companies are less going to
be going through traditional channels
cnbc
um
you know wall street journal mainstream
media new york times they're going to be
bypassing that and going direct to their
community via modern tools you know
blogs podcasts like this one
twitter and you know youtube and all the
modern tools that are out there so it's
just it's an interesting cultural moment
where
west coast companies i think are
starting to take a different view on
this than the east coast
and when you look at it from the
regulator perspective
it almost feels like uh one like you
said there's so much stuff going on uh i
definitely do not envy being a regulator
right now in terms of trying to figure
out uh not only you know what is uh
inbounds or out of bounds but also just
like what to go focus on first i went
through the exercise recently and said
to myself you know if you're a regulator
and you stack rank all the different
things going on in this industry like
what do you even go look at first it's
hard to just do that exercise alone and
so are there areas where you think that
uh regulators and crypto companies a lot
of folks who run other companies or
investors in the industry uh can kind of
meet in the middle like like what is
that middle ground where you think
you're like okay this is the activities
that we should go focus on that can
actually push this forward get to
solutions on some of these issues and
ultimately i think find
some balance between the
kind of economic empowerment the
innovation the job creation all the
things that we know to be positive but
also satisfy whatever the the concerns
are of whether it's regulators
politicians etc
yeah so i totally agree by the way i
have a lot of empathy for regulators in
this space because they have a very hard
job it's so new it's changing so quickly
um you know frankly i i would have a
very hard time getting out there and
sort of publishing clear guidance on it
i think it's i think it's very difficult
but coinbase has been thinking about you
know what we can do to help here in fact
when i was in dc one of the most common
things people asked me was can you help
draft something you and your lawyers
help draft something that would be
proposal a proposal about how this
industry could be regulated more
efficiently right so that coinbase
doesn't have to have
50 plus regulators in just one country
um and then and we don't have this kind
of jump ball between the different
federal agencies so
actually we've been working on a draft
proposal uh a regulatory framework for
the industry we're going to be
publishing that probably in the next two
weeks or so and
it's meant to say not that we have all
the answers but it's a start to the
conversation and i think it could make
sense to have
one agency or basically uh you know a
division within one of the existing
agencies
be the
the single point of regulation a single
federal regulator in the united states
um that can help this this industry get
a little bit of clarity so that this
industry can be built in the united
states effectively and the us can kind
of maintain its position um as a
financial hub and a leader in technology
with with appropriate regulation in
place so i think we basically all want
to think the same thing we want to help
the industry grow but have some
reasonable regulation that's thoughtful
and i guess we want to try to be part of
the solution here not not just engaging
in you know
antagonism and so we're going to put out
a proposal there and i hope people are
willing to come talk to us about it
one of the last things i want to talk
about regulation and move on to some of
the other aspects of the industry is uh
in some weird way um heavy-handed
regulation or uh some stuffing out of
innovation actually could be a tailwind
in a weird way to coinbase right if all
of a sudden uh coinbase is a publicly
traded company sure maybe you can't
launch one or two of your products but
for the most part you almost get
entrenched as uh an incumbent crypto
company uh and startups really struggle
to compete like that would actually be
beneficial right coinbase is probably
worth more money in that situation um
talk a little bit just about like almost
in some way uh wanting clear regulation
and competition being healthy uh and
really driving innovation versus just
you all going which maybe in the legacy
system actually this is what the
incumbents do they go and they advocate
for a bunch of regulation that stops all
competition and really entrenches them
you know you're so right and i'm glad
you brought that up i think it's it's
actually kind of funny how the narrative
gets set sometimes or i think sometimes
all nuance is lost in these uh
conversations and people sometimes look
at it like oh the crypto people don't
want to be regulated
it's actually kind of a ridiculous
statement because number one we already
are regulated we have been for eight
years we have over 50 regulators we
interact with in just one country the
united states
but
moreover the point you made is exactly
right which is honestly regulation would
be the best thing to ever happen to
coinbase because
we're the largest company who can
shoulder that you know we have huge
balance sheet we have tons of lawyers on
staff we already have been leaning into
regulation for many many years
the people that it would harm or the
companies that would harm are smaller
crypto startups and it would honestly
oh yeah again it would entrench these
companies it's like you know look at
what happened is happening with like
kind of google and facebook and all
these things or you know the
um the dodd-frank act or you can kind of
go back and look at all these industries
they basically just enshrine the
incumbents they they sometimes harm
innovation which is bad that's why i'm
more against him but it would almost be
better for coinbase in a weird way yeah
it is uh it's very weird and i think um
you know you you obviously have a great
appreciation for just like how complex
this situation is uh and we're just
talking about uh what i'll call kind of
the uh the incumbent businesses or the
entrepreneurs who run these businesses
we're talking about regulators but
there's a whole bunch of other people at
the table as well everyone from the
retail to the institutional investors
and you can see how very quickly uh many
different interests all get intertwined
and people are just trying to figure it
out um let's move on and kind of talk
about a couple of different areas across
the industry i basically just want to
throw out a couple of uh of what i
consider like the corners of the
industry or areas where it seems like
there's a lot of intellectual and
financial capital uh you know moving in
a trend and then you just elaborate in
terms of what your thoughts are on that
specific uh spot and so maybe we'll
start from the biggest and kind of move
down to some of the the newest or fringe
innovations uh first starting with
bitcoin lightning network uh and a lot
of what i think kind of you started out
and as you said in 2010 when you read
that bitcoin white paper and economic
freedom how do you think about like the
blue chip assets in the space and
bitcoin specifically and how that has
evolved since you first came across that
white paper
yeah
um well you know bitcoin is kind of what
got me super excited about crypto in the
first place and i still am excited about
it i hold a ton of crypto or sorry a ton
of uh bitcoin um
but i think that uh you know it's gonna
it's it's gonna be around forever as
basically you know the gold or the money
of this of this industry um
i
i'm seeing adoption and an interest in
cro across a lot of different assets i
think that's generally a good thing you
know coinbase has always tried to be
agnostic about which one wins and which
one doesn't like we just want to
basically serve our customers with
whatever they want to do
so it's been
actually it's i always am a little
frustrated seeing some of the tribalism
that happens on online and i always you
know twitter is kind of built for um
conflict and warfare and i don't think
it actually represents what the majority
of the industry feels which is probably
a much more nuanced view um which i know
you have as well
uh but yeah i mean bitcoin's great i've
it's been really cool by the way seeing
some of the lightning network adoption
just happening in el salvador with like
mcdonald's and all these things and so
um
i think i think it's great i think we
should keep building that stuff
is it fair to say in some way and i've
started to see this with uh folks who've
been around for a long time that bitcoin
early on was like incredibly
intellectually exciting and and they
really dove into it it pulled them into
this industry uh and there's almost this
sense of like inevitability to it like
you said you know bitcoin's gonna be
around forever uh and people who are
builders they start to become
intellectually interested in other
things as well doesn't mean they lose
interest in in the original thing but
just like their uh aperture almost
expands is that is that kind of a fair
way to think about how your journey in
crypto has happened
yeah sure i mean bitcoin was a huge
breakthrough both in computer science
but also kind of economics and all these
things
uh but it spawned a whole industry and a
lot of other innovation that's sort of
derivative of that work and so i'm
always kind of interested in what's on
the frontier and
um what's getting the most adoption in
different areas so i think we're quickly
going to end up i mean we already are in
this world where the crypto economy is
built of a number of different assets
and blockchains that have different
purposes whether that's to be sort of
gold or payments or security contracts
or
gaming or derivative you know so there's
more and more things that are going to
keep coming out i think we'll my guess
is that we'll eventually be in a world
where um
there's maybe dozens of blockchains but
there's millions or billions of tokens
and you can imagine all kinds of
things that people use those for right
every organization that comes out maybe
even every individual
or
these nfts and um all the stuff these
are all there's going to be so many
tokens that it's like kind of hard to
even imagine where that ends
last question on bitcoin is uh lightning
network you mentioned uh the adoption
especially el salvador obviously and
also corporations there um coinbase and
many other exchanges but uh coinbase i
looked before hasn't integrated with the
lightning network are there certain
milestones or things that you look at
you're like hey once there's a certain
amount of adoption or nodes or capacity
or something that then you guys would
say hey let's go do that or is it
something you're just kind of monitoring
and it's you know day by day is when you
make that decision
yeah you know so i was i was actually
asking the team about this earlier and
looking at some of the adoption stats of
you know you can sort of look at how
many how many bitcoin are tied up in
lightning channels and you can look at
um sort of similar stats across other l2
solutions just to get a sort of a sense
but what i haven't actually been able to
find is a good
metric that just looks at um you know
how many transactions a day are
happening on the different l2 solutions
out there and i think generally
we want to be supporting all of them
that are getting some reasonable
threshold of attraction um
you know but if there's one that's like
really breaking out then that kind of
helps us think about from a ux point of
view which where which ones to emphasize
um because i do think there's
essentially some sort of a cost or an
overhead uh for the for the average
person coming into crypto
like you know we need to expand the
circle of not just like super
sophisticated early adopters to like
what's the next level in the next level
so that's we need to get billions of
people into using crypto and so there's
a cost the more sort of jargon and
options that we throw at them in in
these interfaces um one of the teams
that i spun up this year at coinbase was
called the protocol team
and their whole job is just scale
blockchains okay that's like kind of the
the mandate of that team and they're
looking across all these different
things lightning and the east solutions
and and whatnot and also just scaling it
from um
you know how many taps do you have to do
to like complete a payment which i still
think has way too much friction
uh but the more we can get that kind of
stuff working i feel like it's going to
be a huge unlock for the industry you
know how do we get like the next hundred
million or billion people using crypto
we've got to get the throughput the
scalability increased i think i think
it's just like going from 56k modems to
broadband it's going to be
it's going to be an order of magnitude
increase in usage of crypto and
therefore probably the value in crypto
as well
makes sense um in terms of uh kind of
the next big area is what i'll just call
smart contract platforms and it feels
like maybe three or four years ago it
was ethereum would kind of be the king
there now it seems like uh there's layer
twos on top of ethereum there's a ton of
other smart contract platforms that are
popping up obviously a ton of people
talking about something like a solana
recently how do you look at uh those
smart contract platforms the competition
among that and then how coinbase can
kind of play in that space
yeah so i mean we're generally again
we're blockchain agnostic so we're
trying to add as many as we can um that
are both you know legal in the countries
where we operate but also um
they have hit a certain level of sort of
security like cyber security you know
there are certain times we see
smart contracts where the key is held by
one person or something like that and
they could actually yank everyone's
funds or sort of change people's
balances
those are the kinds of things that we
tend to push back on and we say
all right hey this may not be ready or
if we are going to put it on our
platform we we make a giant kind of
you know user disclosure around that to
make sure people really understand uh
the risks
but
i guess i'm glad that there's more and
more blockchains being created
i think that we are going to see them
sort of specialize over time in their in
what use cases emerge i do think that um
you know i talked with uh cz at binance
about this a little bit where finance
smart chain started to get a lot of
traction and in the one hand i was like
oh this is great we're seeing more and
more adoption i think it was actually a
pretty clever solution in terms of how
they got sort of a fork of ethereum to
scale with fewer nodes
there's always trade-offs around that
but the concern i had over it was that
you know it seems like 50
or more of uh the governance tokens in
this case are controlled by one company
binance and it's even in the name
binance smart chain right although i
think he said they may want to rename it
so i do think it would be a bad thing if
the majority of this activity started to
get created on blockchains that were
more centralized i think that's actually
pretty dangerous
so i really hope that we get
blockchains built that are decentralized
but also scalable
and we can kind of
build you know the right use the right
tool for the right job yeah
when we think about uh things are being
built on top of these smart contract
platforms nfts obviously is a huge topic
of conversation we saw uh various uh
platforms having you know billions of
dollars in sales in a single month uh
and it just feels like everywhere you
turn whether it is uh inside the crypto
industry or outside of the crypto
industry where we're seeing you know
individual athletes musicians teams etc
everyone with ip trying to kind of
figure out where they fit into this how
do you look at nfts and has coinbase
done anything there yet or any plans to
do anything in the nft market
yeah so i think nfts are really an
important trend in crypto and what's
cool by the way is that there's like a
new important trend happening crypto
every three to six months it feels like
so like the pace of innovation just
keeps picking up which is really awesome
um
so nft specifically i mean look i've
never been somebody who
had that that desire to like collect art
or um i never
like really collected anything like um
in the way that people collected
baseball cards or whatever um but that's
i'm sort of you know not a
representative sample i think there's a
huge portion of the population that
really loves this stuff and i think that
it's just going to keep growing like you
know we're probably in a little bit of
an nft bubble right now but i imagine
just like everything crypto it'll kind
of come down but then slowly grow from
there like it's a very real trend um the
other thing that i'm excited about is
not just artists and them getting kind
of better economics in more direct
connections to their their fans and the
resale value and all that
but also the metaverse right there's so
many interesting things happening with
games and um virtual worlds where people
i think are going to own more and more
stuff in these virtual worlds and they
want it to be
something provably unique that they can
actually take off the platform that they
can um sell if they need to or transfer
into another application so anyway long
way of saying i'm very excited about
this um
nothing nothing that i can announce
today but coinbase is very excited about
this space and we're looking at a couple
of different opportunities um
so
it's a real trend i think it's going to
be big for crypto
kind of tangentially related to this is
things like gaming or social tokens and
things that feel like whether they are
nfts or uh nfts are used within them etc
how do you look at some of that other
stuff around the gaming and and the sort
of tokens are we gonna live in a world
where uh you almost have to become
crypto educated or crypto initiated
in order to participate in this stuff
which seems like today uh you've got to
understand crypto to some degree to be
able to participate or is it something
more like the internet where people just
show up they use a platform they
actually don't know what protocols or
underlying technologies are as long as
they can interface with it it's good and
they're and they're a user yeah i mean
actually i think the more that we can
get away from the underlying complexity
the better from a global adoption point
of view
yeah i mean look at the internet is a
great example right in the early days of
the internet you had to dial up with
these modems and understand ip addresses
and and
it was very clunky but the more that
people were just like you know i don't
care about the internet i don't care
about technology but i just want to send
photos to my family and then now there
are billions of people are using
whatsapp and all these things right so
i think the same trend is going to
happen in crypto um there's going to be
probably a billion people in the world
using crypto eventually but a lot of
them will not know anything about how it
works underneath they just they realize
that
this is the best place to get
my financial needs or my gaming the
games are better like the the identity
system is better it has more privacy um
you know hey the value of my assets kind
of go up every overtime instead of being
inflated away right like these are the
things they're going to care about um
and they don't need to know what the
underlying technology actually is
makes sense uh dao seemed to be
something that people now are really
waking up to uh it seems like every day
i'm learning about some new dow that
somebody's creating how do you view
those is there something that coinbase
will do there or anything that you're
personally interested in
yeah i think dials are a really
important innovation and it's also going
to be a really big trend i mean it
already is but i think it's going to be
huge in the future and so
um we're seeing all this really cool
governance experimentation happening now
which i think is by the way if you zoom
out long term you know people are always
talking about like what's what's a
better form of democracy or how can we
improve this and i think you know long
long term uh this is kind of influenced
by people like biology for nevas and
whatnot but we're seeing people move
away from
um the country or the state that they
live in as their primary source of
identity and governance and they're
starting to think about these online
communities as
another thing that they really truly
identify with and i think that's where
we're going to see the most important
experimentation with new forms of
governance
so
doubts are really important for that how
all communities and society could do
governance but also
companies and um
it's really cool to see uh people moving
more money into these things so one of
the things we want to do at coinbase
actually is is help people make dows
more easily right um i i want it in an
ideal world anybody should be able
without understanding how to create
smart contracts and whatnot come into a
product that's really simple
um
publish a dow
invite people to it funds get allocated
um maybe
there's like standard templates of
things that you might want to put in
there like payroll or different voting
systems and then you can actually go out
and raise money and you know market it
to people on coinbase and and the rest
of the crypto community
this would be an incredible achievement
i think because it'll just make
innovation happen faster in the world
today the way that companies get formed
where you know first of all you have to
kind of live in a city that has angel
investors which there aren't that many
of them
so it's already sort of discriminatory
by by default then you have to interface
with a bunch of lawyers
which can be expensive um and then you
have to go through this kind of archaic
process to eventually uh go public and
coinbase went through it right like i
would much rather be in a world where
uh any
any startup anywhere in the world can go
through the formation docks kind of like
stripe atlas or you know the new
delaware c corp but it's it's much
simpler it's faster you can raise money
in a more egalitarian fair way and
eventually even go public all on the
blockchain
um
this is where i think we're going and
that's going to be a huge unlock for for
innovation and dowser going to be i
think like the new delaware c corp
um
there's even some things about it that
are you know not like the old system
which is that you know i think you could
have collaboration of people who have
never met each other they don't even
know who each other are right that's a
pretty powerful idea but the wisdom of
the crowds could kind of allocate funds
more efficiently so anyway i'm very
bullish on dow's i think that we need to
make them like everything in crypto much
much easier to use and that's that's
generally where i think coinbase can add
value like we're not the company who's
gonna put out the next big um like we
probably would have never invented dows
but what we can do is make daos
trusted and easier to use that's kind of
the value that we're typically able to
bring to the ecosystem and then help get
the next 100 million or billion people
hopefully eventually to use these things
because they are now simpler to use and
trusted
one thing that really strikes me uh in
talking to you is you thought very
deeply about some of the what most
people would consider corners of this
industry uh
if you weren't running coinbase and you
were a founder uh starting all over
again is there like one area where you
say hey like this is where i would go
explore first or this would be like the
idea that i think would be really
interesting to pursue uh or is it all
just hey we're just gonna do it at
coinbase and so you haven't really
thought about that type of stuff
well i mean coinbase is definitely a
multi-product company so like i feel
very lucky actually we have the ability
to create new products from within
coinbase
um and we do that with
you know our 70 2010 resource allocation
so 70 of our resources go to the core
stuff we're doing it makes most of our
revenue 20 percent are on these adjacent
bets and then 10 percent are venture
bets so we actually built this really
cool system internally
i'll answer the core of your question in
a second but they you know we basically
have a system now internally where any
employee or group of employees can pitch
a panel of people internally uh twice a
year and if you get one of the people on
the panel it's very important it's by
the way it's one of the people it
doesn't have to be unanimous yes you
don't need to get a yes from me even
um
then you can get your 10 project funded
and
we've done a number of those now some of
them you'll see launching in by the end
of this year
but um that's our way to kind of build
startups within a bigger company and
continue to be innovative now
i'm fine with lots of different models
right so people can stay in coinbase and
build these and
keep their coinbase equity and
compensation um they could also leave
coinbase by the way i'm supportive of
that too we have coinbase ventures where
we've invested in a number of employees
you've left or even external
founders um so anyway back to your
question about what would i create today
in the crypto space maybe um
if i were to do another one i mean
the thing is there's so many cool
opportunities i think coming out in
crypto it's
there's i think decentralized identity
is really interesting i think there's a
bunch of um
virtual like somebody should go make an
oculus app with a virtual world where
you can have nfts and digital goods
right
i think that
um
there's a lot of interesting stuff
happening with daos um so
you know
just going and staying on the forefront
of that like what's the next evolution
of how these um
these financial primitives and these
dows are going to start to interact with
each other
i think you know there's there's a lot
of building blocks like even just like
payroll like getting payroll working in
crypto is a really big one um nfts could
be even easier for the average creator
to use so
there's so many opportunities it's it's
more about like what people are actually
passionate about like take the thing if
you're passionate about crypto then what
else are you passionate about if it's
art and crypto maybe like the
intersection of that is nfts if it's
identity and crypto or governance and
crypto you can kind of find the
intersection and what's the thing that
is most uh applicable to you as a
founder you mentioned coinbase ventures
and uh you all have done quite a bit of
investing uh from what i've seen on
various cap tables or deals that i've
done uh you guys have invested in a lot
of great companies um is there ever a
concern that coinbase ventures is almost
like too good of an investor uh and the
equity of those holdings ends up growing
to be uh too material uh for coinbase or
shareholder equity or anything like that
i think of it almost like the alibaba
problem with uh with yahoo um and like
how do you think through ventures versus
the the core business
yeah
well
so
let's see
in some ways like you know it would be
great right if these things i think that
i think that portfolio of investments
we've made with coinbase ventures is
going to be huge it's going to be
enormous
um now i'd be a little bit sad if it
ends up if we end up like yahoo i'd much
rather we end up like google or
something right and so
actually that's that's one of the big
things that i talk to the team about
internally is
if you're if you know we were kind of
one of the early crypto companies and we
got big
but that doesn't mean that we should be
complacent or rest on our laurels
because
you know yahoo had like over 90 market
share and google was this tiny startup
they could have bought it for you know
probably tens of millions of dollars
something and they and they completely
got beat by them so i'm always sort of
like paranoid about what is the next
thing that we're that's getting big in
crypto that we're gonna miss out on i
think for us coinbase to be relevant we
have to continually reinvent ourselves
we have to continually disrupt ourselves
we need to have enough um
we need to strike this balance between
okay yes that we're interfacing with all
these regulators and it sounds scary and
we're going to clean up the industry
make more clarity and all that
but at the same time let's try new
things you know we can never sort of
have risk aversion uh creep in to the
company and so we always say uh one of
our
one of our values at coinbase is about
repeatable innovation that's part of why
we do this 10
resource allocation and we have people
come in and pitch and you know even if i
don't think it's a good idea but
somebody on the panel champions it it'll
get funded this is all very deliberately
designed for us to hopefully continue to
be relevant and have a portfolio of
products that okay maybe some of them
don't work but others are just getting
huge
um over time that's i think how we're
going to become a very relevant and big
company over many decades and hopefully
you know many generations um not just uh
like a flash in the pan that has a big
meteoric rise and then it becomes
irrelevant
yeah what you're hitting on here a lot
of is kind of the cultural element so
about a year ago you put out a post i
can't remember if it was you personally
or the company but there's a post put
out about uh coinbase as a
mission-driven company
and there was a whole bunch of stuff
addressing you know kind of social
issues and how the company was going to
handle that moving forward but it also i
think reinforced just the culture at
coinbase in general
since that point what have you learned
are there positives negative takeaways
like like how has that uh kind of
evolved over time uh knowing that uh one
we've gone through an economic crisis
there's been a public health crisis
there's been a shift to remote work like
there's so much going on in the world uh
how has the culture evolved and how do
you think of it today
yeah so that was a very important moment
for me as a founder and just in our
culture at coinbase because
that's a great example of how you know a
company can
as it gets bigger
it can actually lose alignment so all
kinds of problems can happen in big
companies right like the benefit of a
big company is you get more and more
people so you can accomplish more and
more things multiple products hopefully
increase the pace of innovation
but the challenge is that sometimes you
get misalignment you get
miscommunication
um you know you think that as a leader
you're being clear and setting a
direction but it turns out different
people interpret it in different ways
and whatnot so this is a little bit of
what happened last year which led to
that which led to me writing that post
which was that um i recently was getting
the sense internally that we were having
division we were not aligned about what
we should actually be focused on and it
was in the middle of this kind of
cultural zeitgeist about
um all the social issues that were
happening at that time which were you
know incredibly important things in the
world
uh but the problem where i realized we
were not aligned was that there was a
a small but quite vocal group of people
inside the company this was not unique
to coinbase by the way every single ceo
i talked to in tech was really
struggling with this same problem at the
same time at that time and probably
still to this day
um
and that that increasingly vocal but
small group within the company was
saying hey i actually think that our
mission means something different we
should probably change our priorities
and spend more of our time
internally debating these issues um but
also taking action as a company to try
to solve these issues you know um the
things at that time were around um you
know social justice and police brutality
all kinds of things
so
what i realized was that this was um
this was going to be a big problem for
us because i had failed as a leader to
set a clear direction and made it made
the actual mission of the company clear
and it was resulting in things like
employees walking out which had never
happened at coinbase over particularly
contentious issues which i felt were
kind of unrelated to what we were doing
as a company
so that was a that was a moment where i
finally said um you know what i've got
to get people back aligned towards the
right uh the right mission and that's
going to be a bit of a painful process
because i know not everybody agrees and
that's part of being a leader is you
have to kind of be willing to make a
decision sometimes even if you know some
people aren't going to like it so i put
out that mission focused blog post um
you know when i was at the all hands
kind of sharing it before the post was
made externally um it was really tough i
was like almost crying actually while
going through it because i knew people
were going to be so frustrated but with
it or and upset
but um
ultimately we decided to make a uh exit
package available to any employee who
kind of wasn't on board with this new
direction that was my way of saying hey
you know we didn't set clear
expectations if this is where you feel
like we should be focusing our time and
so um
let's let's make it a win-win let's have
everybody end up at a good place about
five percent of the company ended up
taking that exit package which um you
know ultimately it was sad to lose
colleagues but it ultimately was it was
a really good thing for coinbase because
now
the company feels much more aligned we
don't spend our days um in the office
sort of debating all of the problems of
the world and getting into controversial
stuff if it's not related to our mission
which is creating more economic freedom
and using cryptocurrency to do that uh
so anyway i i would actually recommend
it to any kind of founder out there or
company that's that's struggling with
this
um i don't want to claim that it's the
right approach for every company every
every founder and ceo has to kind of
choose what kind of culture they want to
create but
if if it's not working for for you
internally i i do i think creating a
mission focused company that's much more
specific about there's one big problem
in the world we're trying to solve and
we're going to be focused on that we're
even going to be political about that
but we're not going to get engaged in
everything else because it just creates
distraction and
kind of anger division internally i
would totally recommend it as an
approach
kind of tangentially related to this is
this idea of uh remote work and not
having a headquarters i know that you
guys also publicly stated uh you are a
remote only company a remote first
company
and you no longer have a dedicated
headquarters uh talk a little bit about
how
you know kind of being a mission-driven
business but also thinking about how you
work uh seems to have been kind of top
of mind as well over the last 18 months
or so
yeah so being remote first for us is
another important step that we did so
uh remote first means it's not that 100
of people are remote we still have
offices and people can go into those
offices if they want but everybody is
required to operate even if they're in
the office as if um you know in a way
that's welcoming to people who are in a
remote environment
so
the reason we did that was that
basically i felt like during covid we
tried it
it worked really well it in fact it it
unlocked a couple of really important
benefits it had a few drawbacks but i
thought that the benefits far outweighed
the drawbacks so the benefits were that
number one our hiring pipeline
got much better and so but pre going
going remote first one of the biggest
reasons people left coinbase or did not
join coinbase was due to location it was
commute commute issues or they didn't
want to relocate to be within commuting
distance of one of our offices
so
think about that like what percentage of
people in the world were within
commuting distance one of our offices it
was probably
less than one percent of the people in
the world so we literally 100x the top
of the funnel of potential candidates
that we could hire from right so that
alone is just a huge thing to getting
top talent in the right seats is kind of
one of the core things that has made
coinbase successful and i think it will
continue to be in the future
now
put on top of that there's a lot of
important benefits to employees if in
that environment so
if you want to spend more time with your
kids if you want to travel parts of the
year and live in different locations
you know these are all incredible
benefits that i think frankly any
company who doesn't start to offer these
in the tech space like you know
manufacturing and retail and stuff you
have to be in one location but for
companies that don't have to do it
i think they're eventually going to lose
their best people to remote first
companies because it's just such a huge
employee perk
now there are some drawbacks right to be
totally fair so one of the drawbacks is
that
it's not as fun you don't feel this like
social camaraderie that happens um as
much when you get into an office and
there's kind of fun moments that happen
at the lunch table and the water cooler
and all that and there's serendipity
there's creativity there's sparks of
innovation sometimes that happen
but the way that we solve that is that
actually once a quarter at least once a
quarter people at coinbase are still
going to get together with somebody in
person especially once we get more of
the coveted stuff figured out
um whether that's your team or it's just
a bunch of cross-functional people who
all happen to live in that city where
you're in or um various things like that
so we're going to get people together at
least once a quarter
and i think that's our way to mitigate
the drawbacks of it so the last part you
mentioned was around coinbase and its
headquarters in san francisco so yeah we
made a conscious effort actually to say
we don't have a headquarters anymore
um i think this that's actually pretty
important in a remote first environment
because if you do have one building
where the ceo or the executive team is
kind of going into that office every day
as i quote headquarters it's it sets the
wrong tone from the top because
basically anybody who wants to be close
to the executive team or whatever
is going to start to go into that office
too and so it starts to make like a de
facto in-office benefit and so i wanted
to kind of lead by example and not go
into any i i don't go into any one
particular coinbase office if i happen
to be in a city somewhere i'll step in
there and say hi to people but
as a general rule i'm not going into any
one location we actually very quickly
after covet just naturally without even
trying this not a single one of our
executive team was living in san
francisco and so we said you know what
oh and by the way you know san francisco
had its own challenges at that time i
mean there was
a bunch of policies frankly we didn't
feel very welcome in san francisco at
times like the the government there was
just kind of a little bit hostile
towards tech companies um there's a very
weird cultural thing happening in san
francisco where you know it has the
heart of it is this amazing idea which
is people who are optimistic about the
future and able to build it
which is what attracted me to san
francisco and why i still love it
um there's a very frustrating and
challenging thing happening where
there's a there's a negativity towards
that um within some of the the
population there and there's like kind
of like very punitive taxes which make
it like much more expensive sometimes
like twenty thousand dollars a year more
for us to hire an employee in san
francisco and all these things which
make no sense
so we felt like look if we're not wanted
here um we're going to be a
decentralized company anyway let's move
the head let's just say we have no
headquarters it's more in line with us
embracing decentralization as a crypto
company anyway
and um it's been working really well for
us as well
so the last question i have for you uh
and i i don't even know how you would
evaluate this but uh if you were
thinking of starting coinbase today uh
would you do it as a centralized or as a
decentralized type effort right
i'm assuming at some point this has kind
of come up whether it's due to
regulatory stuff whether it's due to
remote work or whatever but how do you
evaluate like centralization versus
decentralization around coinbase itself
and maybe even like could you
decentralize the company in the future
or how do you think about all that
yeah that's a funny question if i was
creating it today i mean
so i would definitely go remote first um
i would definitely
i think i would lean more into some
decentralization aspects in the sense
that um
like we'd probably just put a lot of our
documentation we have internally i just
make it all public and just do it out in
the open i think it's like good
marketing it's good transparency
um
we might even be like hire pseudonymous
people you know what i do it as a dao so
i think the dao the dao tools need to
still get a little bit refined um in the
sense that i think you should have a dao
is probably like the governing body of
these organizations but in local
countries where you operate you may
actually still need a c-corp that's like
controlled by the dao
um
there's a company called research hub
which i'm helping get off the ground and
it's it's creating an online community
like github for science it's trying to
help accelerate science and make it more
like open source software and with that
structure we actually did go and create
a dao
and a c corp and it's been like a very
interesting um process for me to figure
out
what that the future of the corporation
is going to look like in that world and
so i'm sort of beta testing it there
trying to iron out a lot of the details
what's super frustrating is like there's
no well paved road so you have to spend
more with the lawyers and they don't
they can't give you any kind of clear
answer they're like well no one's done
it before so try this it seems like a
reasonable thing and we'll see how it
goes so i think my hope is that by
learning from some of those experiments
like with research hub
we can then go and productize this at
coinbase and make it easy for anybody to
create that future type of entity in
just like a you know simple interface
you don't have to spend tens of thousand
dollars tens of thousands of dollars
with lawyers
um but i yeah that's the direction i
would had for sure if i were creating a
company today yeah it is absolutely
fascinating to think about how quickly
all this has moved since you started
coinbase to where we are today you know
everything from nation states adopting
bitcoin to uh talking about you know
tangible things around dows and nfts and
and all of that and then obviously in
the next you know five ten years uh
it'll be pretty incredible to see
everything else that gets created um
where can we send people if they're
interested in uh working at coinbase
following you on the internet or just
kind of learning more about what you and
the rest of the team are doing
yeah well um coinbase is a great place
to start a crypto career if you're
trying to learn more about crypto or you
want to eventually even want to start a
company i think we're a good place for
that you can check out coinbase.com
careers
you can follow us on on twitter
obviously at coinbase or uh myself at
brian underscore armstrong
so thanks for yeah following us along
and hopefully we can all keep building
the crypto economy together absolutely
well listen thank you so much for taking
the time to do this i know you got a
million things going on hopefully
everyone enjoyed this and we'll
definitely have to do it again in the
future
yeah that was great thanks for the
questions and the interview that's cool
all right all right i hope you guys
enjoyed that uh absolutely incredible in
terms of uh just how clearly i think
brian has talked about
and thought about his business the
industry
obviously there's some challenges right
now across the industry and uh and
regulators and companies are trying to
figure it out which i think i'm
optimistic about so are other people uh
but pretty incredible to uh to hear kind
of his perspective there i appreciate
him doing it and hopefully all of you uh
ended up uh learning a ton as well uh
from uh from this
john
you uh
you you and coinbase are you friends
with coinbase right yeah i love what
they're building there
ryan's a smart guy he knows what he's
doing
exactly all right before uh before we
end today we got another minute or two
uh we need to ask what does the atm
think about this
very good commentary very good
commentary until joe comes back i'm not
shaving and we're going to keep talking
to the atm when joe comes back you're
not shaving till joe comes back not
coming not shaving until joe comes back
let's go
i'm cheating because i know when he's
coming back
but i'm not shaving till joe comes back
protest this is my silent protest uh all
right we're at 1.5 k likes i got things
to do here's what we're gonna do we're
gonna pick one person
one person
and we're giving free merch you guys can
get to 2k that's your fault not mine i
just do my best to bring great guests
talk a little bit educate get john in
here crack a couple jokes
you see you see the atm moving like what
when it when it does the little uh thing
right on screen there it's kind of like
it's trying to talk yeah all right i
give you credit you do bring some
amazing guests on this show
i'll give credit where credit's due what
do you want to go to lunch together or
something after this we can if you want
if you're buying we're going
i'm gonna let john and joe pick guests
for a week at some point just you guys
yeah yeah exactly you don't want that
kind of heat on this show
exactly um all right so let's do this uh
what are we gonna have people do here's
what i want you to do if you take the
link
uh and
actually not even that let's just make
it super simple for people
leave a comment right now
and explain why you like the show
if you leave a comment and explain why
you like the show we'll pick one person
right now give them free merch and then
we're out of here
you're feeling super nice today this is
rare yeah well i mean they came up 400
likes short which is nuts to me nuts to
me
ready i'm just gonna pick one person
real quick as they all are leaving the
comments here we go
i'm gonna look for somebody that i know
is here every day too that's a key piece
to me that's what i care about
consistency john you over there you care
about who makes you laugh who's
following you on twitter i don't care
let's see here we go
i'm gonna go with
oh now they're flooding in
sunny
cara correas gonna tag you real quick
here sonny you win
dm john
on twitter
what's his at on here i just i just
messaged him
i appreciate all of you
honestly appreciate all of you uh
constantly uh tuning in here hopefully
hopefully you guys are learning that's
that is my goal with this is to make
sure everyone learns uh john joe they do
a a ton of work um
john's really excited i said something
nice about him uh they do a ton of work
uh to get the doc right well john does a
lot of work to get the doc ready joe you
know i get excited the pre-show meetings
when we go through this you guys don't
understand we put a lot of work into
this show so i really appreciate
everyone's support yeah a little
pre-show meeting we've got matt and
jordy there me john joe when he's in the
hospital no just show up putting your
piece in spit some fire
this is
research yeah little prep uh so i
appreciate you all watching uh hopefully
you guys are learning uh it would mean
the world to me just smash the like
button make sure you subscribe to the
channel uh if uh if you are subscribed
to the channel then you will know when
we go live you'll see all the videos all
that type of stuff that would be amazing
that's all i got i don't know what else
you got anything else
what's today oh good day to pay off your
credit card
make sure you go to sofi.com go ahead
and download the app
that's it see ya hope you enjoyed the
interview
see you tomorrow
[Music]
you